chris hanson here of hanson vs predators
to catch a predator and have a seat with
chris hanson
and there's something you need to know
it'd be a shame if something were to
surface about zach's past join our
membership program for early access
in no ads otherwise zach may be
taking a seat right over there this
isn't a threat my name
i'm just a really really good
investigator
i'll be watching two
we're here defying the odds uh
the odds are stacked against us every
week we come on here especially when ela
hasn't muted her phone
or computer and there's like
notification sounds going off like crazy
they said it couldn't and by the way
aren't you the one that is literally
always giving me [ __ ] every episode
and the minute we start the episode
ela's over here blowing up
so what's what do you have to say for
you it's your fault how was it my fault
i don't know you did something yeah it's
my fault you use my laptop or something
what dude you owe me a huge apology
right now
i'm not apologizing for anything wow
all right we'll talk after the show but
the one
the one thing we can all agree on is
that
they said we would never come back we
would never show our faces again
yet here we are this is the h3 podcast
and we will never die
we will never hide our faces in shame
like to thank me andes for sponsoring us
and i'd like to give a shout out to
all of our beautiful members
we added a discord server by the way now
for our members only and it's popping
off like crazy
what's really crazy if you do not become
a member
by hitting the join button is that chris
hanson
actually you guys saw are called open
there
it's incredible that chris hansen
i think what he said zach is that he's
willing to make
uh accusations against you
zack if they don't subscribe
because please sign up i don't want any
[ __ ] coming out
yeah well he said and i'm not actually
surprised
they they we got him to say that because
what he said is i'm not
saying zach did anything but i'm a
really good investigator
so what do you what do you think he
meant by that i you know i
i have a i have a dark past so i think
everyone needs to become a member and
sign up
because i don't want any of that coming
out see the way the way that i
interpreted that
is that he's he's willing to make [ __ ]
up about you
oh well that's not good either so but
the fact that you just admitted to it
makes me think that
i think something happened on that
cruise ship yeah
what was that i said there's something
you're not telling us about the cruise
uh you know i i don't want to reveal
that
there may be i got you well regardless
please sign up to be a member is
very helpful we need members times are
tough
i'm begging i'm begging you um
there's some i'm kind of sad though
today because
something literally just happened before
we started rolling
we are promoting a teddy fresh shirt
that's coming out on thursday
that we've all been really excited and
happy about
and it's something that i designed the
concept of
here it is it's a teddy bear and a
raincoat
and on the sleeve it shows the fork the
weather forecast which is rain
it's rain every day
and underneath the teddy bear in the
raincoat it says i have crippling
anxiety
but i it's weird because i didn't
anticipate this at
all but um
people are super upset yeah people are
really
angry about this shirt saying that we
are
uh romanticizing mental illness or that
we're just
commercializing mental illness but the
comments are really
very i mean just mean i think
but no they're not mean they're just
they don't like it they don't like it i
guess i feel personally attacked maybe
because i designed it
i mean i didn't do the art but like the
concept the eye of [ __ ] anxiety
the thing is i guess it's hard to convey
but maybe if this was like h
m or something or some big company but
like here's the thing
i have suffered from generalized anxiety
disorder my entire
adult life right i see this
as this bear
when i had generalized anxiety order
disorder so bad that i couldn't leave
the house i couldn't sleep for like
eight days in a row i didn't sleep
i was so ashamed and embarrassed that
about my condition or whatever i was
going through
i couldn't communicate it to my parents
or even the closest people to me and i
suffered so much more because of that
excuse me the one thing i think looking
back as if i would have just opened up
and talked about it early on
i think it would have helped me so much
but i held it all in
and i think that it made the condition
so much worse it cascaded
and i don't know for me what i see in
despair is like it's rainy all week
the bear's got his raincoat on he's got
crippling anxiety
but you still gotta go outside and face
the world and that's kind of how i
my whole attitude towards anxiety is
that you can never once you surrender to
it then you lose and so to me it is a
very personal
statement and i definitely am not trying
to romanticize it but
but i know i just people are so upset
it's like 100 of the comments are just
like
uh not they're thinking the worst of it
of us
but to me you know i feel bad
i just feel bad because i didn't expect
it and obviously i don't want to offend
people
so i'm kind of sad about it and i'm
conflicted as well because on one hand
i love the design i think the design is
great
i mean i for me it's just something that
didn't really
come up for some reason neither of us
really thought that was going to be an
issue
maybe it's because i have the condition
maybe i just took it for granted
yeah so the shirts are already made like
it's already done
so we can't change anything i see
people's point
in a way you know i see both sides i
guess
i think the fact that they don't know
who i am or my story
can upset people more but like someone
suggested they're like here
if you put this then then we would all
be happy it said everything will be okay
but that to me that's not really that
wasn't the concept
that i want i wanted people to know like
i feel like people are gay keeping
like mental illness a little bit they
says
uh we can't you can't romanticize
depression and anxiety
or or if you you're not allowed to wear
this shirt unless you have anxiety or
something like that
to me the fact that i wasn't able to
talk about it made it so much worse
if you can just come out and talk about
it and say it i think that
is way more healing so i don't even
understand that perspective necessarily
as someone
who suffers from gad generalized anxiety
disorder
i mean i'm on antidepressants i've done
therapy i mean this is a
this is a huge daily part of my life
uh but i think i don't know i just it
feels bad
it feels really bad on the comments on
instagram and twitter are horrible
people are saying we're canceled and
teddy fresh is over
because of one design that i made and
it's my fault like everything
so great now i have crippling anxiety
at least i can wear the shirt now you
have a depression when you need to oh
[ __ ]
we need to make the follow-up shirt on
the back it should say i have crippling
depression
and i'm and but now i can wear it people
can't complain
i the shame is though that like it's
such a cool shirt
um you know so there you go
and by the way maybe it's the the what i
tweeted the text it says [ __ ] anxiety
don't mean you ain't cute
but actually there's a story behind that
too because some days i would get up
i was so anxious i hated being alive but
i would look and maybe
i would look in the mirror and be like
you look good today you're having a good
day
i swear to god i remember thinking that
to myself like you know what
your hair looks good today and i i don't
know why that memory sticks out to me
because it's just so ridiculous the
the juxtaposition of feeling so bad but
then having this moment of looking in
the mirror and be like you look pretty
good today though
i didn't leave the house by the way but
i'm just saying
so there you have it
i thought sila um
i probably you can blame me for this one
i probably would have changed it if i
could but we can't
yeah yeah i mean i have crippling
anxiety i
could have said keep on trucking there
kiddos
i don't know anyway i just thought it
was interesting
i just wanted to see like we totally
didn't anticipate it yeah didn't even
cross my mind that someone would be
offended by it but there it is it's 100
percent offended
here we are like it's one of those times
when we
you see like gucci makes this like black
face
mask and we're like how did no one know
like in the whole of gucci's company no
one
said anything everyone thought it was
fine let me pull that here we are
yeah here we are we become the gucci
blackface mask people
hold on let me find it this is it
this is who we are ela this is who we've
become
oh man um well gucci didn't get canceled
over it so
that's the weirdest thing oh we're the
gucci face mask people
[Laughter]
cut that seems so much worse that does
seem so much worse i have to say
although judging by the comments
you wouldn't think so why would you wear
that why would you even wear that
why would you even wear that i mean my
god
by the way i like gucci their clothes is
like just incredible
the quality and make it everything but
this is a weird design
i guess it's meant to be yeah it's
definitely meant to be a while
if i saw someone walking down the street
i would like triple quadruple take them
like
but you [ __ ] i'm sure the designer was
completely like thinking something else
in
in their mind and so here it is actually
so this goes right maybe you can relate
can you relate i guess i can now i am
that person
i love the mouth hole it's just so
bizarre that's funny
it is it's just everything the colors
really make it like so
insensitive probably well actually when
you see it
so it's just around the mouth with the
picture that they were promoting
it's like tucked into oh that's racist
that's racist i think it's the fact that
it's black and red that
just yeah yeah yeah not good well anyway
that's us
so uh ethan and ela are confirmed uh
boomer [ __ ] bags who are out of touch
[ __ ] we're gonna have to run everything
by ian first
i feel like because ian you were saying
you
could have anticipated i just think you
know depression anxiety and
uh it's all such a giant spectrum
everyone experiences it in such a
subjective way
that whenever there's money involved
you're gonna get the whole range of
reaction
we didn't get the whole range we just
got the bad ones
i mean you were saying there was some
pop yeah there was some good one
actually there was some really nice
supportive ones that people were like
hey i have anxiety and generalized
anxiety disorder and uh
i like the shirt so shout out to them
anyway let's move on enough about
poor unfortunate counsel the h3 and
let's talk
about uh this great
what no nothing what was that all i
heard was dan go foot
it's a feet feet
why would dance why did you say feet
because it's a meme on our show
and i want to talk about feet oh we got
to talk about
feet that one all right jeez i mean it
threw me off all i heard was feet
i was like what the hell that's okay
okay so we just went
issued an apology and pledged to donate
100 of the profits to a mental health
charity yes so that was a crisis
that all happened live during the plugin
and we just yeah and then came back and
now we're finishing that
episode recording is taking like a whole
day to just do 10 minutes so far
i know we've made it about 13 minutes
into the show so far after
starting three hours yeah we start at 10
it's 1 30 now
well i'm glad we did it because i yeah i
think it's the right thing to do
even though i just anyway i would
probably talk about it
yeah we talked into that but that's why
it's good that things happen people say
their feedback and
you respond i mean honestly we just
didn't see it that way and now we do
it's that simple yeah it is that simple
i'm i am a pro health advocate i'm
openly
talking about my mental health issues i
have always suffered from mental health
issues i take
20 milligrams of lexapro a day every
morning
that's a high dosage just so you don't
so just so you know
my penis barely feels anything it's like
slapping it against
uh i mean you could put nails through my
[ __ ] i wouldn't feel it
i mean i take like support too yeah so
we're alexa pro family
by the way my mom does oh your mom's my
sister does now
um yeah now people are going to start
saying
oh well now you're advocating for people
everybody to take looks pro okay hold on
let's go issue an apology
well there's a lot of truth it's the
it's the pharmaceutical companies uh
being evil
there was a lot of trauma in your family
after your dad passed that's when
everybody started on the
lexa pro yeah am i allowed to say that
yes of course yeah because i just wanted
only been two years yeah it's just
that that was a big impact on your
family
oh i had to go get a saudi to [ __ ]
calm me down too
anyway hey it's a good cause let's give
him some money
i just love the shirt you could have
written under anything on there like i
what if we wrote under the shirt i fart
on my hand and smell it
that's kind of a good caption should i
pull up the shirt no
i farted my hand and smell it even dan
didn't laugh with that
yeah no dan i don't find farts amusing
not amusing how about joking
yeah oh yeah you should i farted on feet
i farted on feet
it should say dude that's a good i want
to smell feet
i want to smell feed is pretty funny i'm
not going to utter that what about you
just did though that's a sound bite
oh no i hate faith just
for the i don't like fit
in general like you hate my feet i mean
i don't have anything personal against
your fit i just don't find feet i always
thought i had nice
interesting it's one of my few nice kids
i don't like looking at fate
wow feet are pretty but that's i think
that's why people have a foot fetish
because
it's so repulsive and people like like
that you know
because they like to be demeaned or
whatever
poor female but i don't think it's a i
don't think it's a demeaning thing
how is it not you're sucking on
someone's toes it's definitely like a
submission
dominant thing well i agree with that
thank you zach
and if anyone knows it's zach zach
understands that
despite the meme i don't know a whole
lot about the federation
yeah she sent you this is what belle
said it's a therapy
yeah it's like a comforting all right
let's move on for christ
i mean we've not really we haven't
covered anything
oh yeah yeah people were so upset i was
just like whoa
all righty so with that being said i was
meaning to start with a
lighthearted goof uh it's a little late
for that
but let's try to get back on track here
hey this is the h3 podcast what do i
always say at the beginning
they think nobody's got it dan
that we're not coming back we're never
coming back this is it they said we
would never be back
right well here we are here it is guys
uh we got mobility scooter memes what is
that it's got a ferrari sticker on it
what is that i love it and it just he
can't even hit the curb though
it's got a ferrari sticker on it
i love that he was just filming he's
just filming it because it's so
goofy and then it tips the [ __ ] over
what is that it's got a ferrari sticker
on it
oh god wait i gotta watch this
was he trying to hop the curb or did he
just accidentally
it's got a ferrari sticker
i don't know oh bro i don't like the i
don't want the gas
anymore i want a fully contained isn't
this thing so cute
it looks like it's awesome it's like
theodore's toy but like actual
oh yeah i think it's just a mobility
scooter that's like all purpose
what is that it's got a ferrari sticker
on it i
love it there's no balance
there's just no structural integrity
it's so narrow and tall
yeah so just it took a slight small
curve and just totally
how frequently does that happen to them
on it he's like damn it not again
but that's gonna be a pretty bad impact
for someone who's like you know
yeah has mobility issues too i mean
that's true
can you even call that a mobility
scooter at that point i mean that's just
a car
it's a that's a mobility yeah it's a car
that's an automobile i believe it's
called an
auto mobility disability mode
i love the disability mobility mobile
so can you guys look up look uh zachary
ian look that up let me see
where what's the price and how can i buy
that
power wheel uh
i think dan's making a joke there was a
toy when we were kids
uh there's more me that's actually a lot
of memes that were generated from the
last
episode when we opened belle's uh
mystery box
some fan art ela the kitty girl
and ethan the protector warrior it's
funny because we're at the same height
yeah why am i so short but people always
draw us like that they always do me like
tall and like skinny and you're short
and chubby
i mean it's pretty funny it's funny i
guess that's our
that's what our caricature i think first
vibe is
exactly i think for a girl you're tall
i'm a normal hype but i think the
fatness it's easy for people to be like
oh he's
i mean that's a pretty accurate
portrayal to be honest i look pretty
cool
that's really cute i think i look pretty
cold my sword and my teddy fresh shirt
yeah it's another art
which is i think conan the barbarian
that's what i thought
at first two but i saw other people
commenting it's from uh
what do you call it um oh like the mars
saga
thing they made a movie about it a
couple years ago how's that not conan
well the artist might have been the same
artist that did the conan stuff too
i'm not sure oh this one cracked man
john carter there you go that's what i
couldn't think of the name either doing
the hey go
what is it how's it hey go face can you
try that you've never
tried it i did it
you don't want to try it i don't want to
do it and then i'll be memed forever
yeah it would be but that's good
hey girl if you just do this ela
like a billion people will beat off to
you i don't know
talk to me baby vin diesel is requesting
a hegel face
ben do you want to see it [ __ ]
beautiful well ben
diesel how are you going to say no to
vin diesel
all right when grandma gives you 100
bucks for christmas
i i was stuck
that's totally the face yeah bells tuck
a hundred dollar bill in like a little
teddy bear this one ian yes
our ian made and first of all you know i
have to commend you
on the h3 ps4 oh what the hell
yeah but why did you write bel why did
you write
delphine edition edition delphine i
think it's the french version right
yeah the regular dark souls cover has
that on it
say what it says like definitive edition
and then definitive edition in french
because
multi-region release yeah
you actually may look pretty dope
simpsons
hd pot damn you [ __ ] thought of
everything bro it's got the fupa rating
for the
17 how much time did this take you
oh no like 10 15 minutes wow really in
ian's is a real stamp
ian is such a creative uh
toward the force that i'm not kidding
he's
he's such a talent i wish i could
utilize that more
i appreciate that thank you that was a
sound bite
take me for real you're getting better i
appreciate that thank you
that was real wait it was real that one
was real the first one was
am i right you can assume ninety percent
of the time you hear
me that's the sound bite see i can i'm
getting good at this
try to trick me zack and then i'll call
it out that should be the game
all right deal anyway good job ian
ela making and only fans i sleep
ethan making on fans real [ __ ]
i got a really weird email from a fan
which i think was in earnest
where he was like begging me to make an
only fans
really yeah whoa
so
it didn't seem like it was a meme he was
well no he seems
he did seem serious that's why it struck
out what seemed serious about it
because he was just he was do you want
me to read i mean i could probably find
it
but he just was writing in really
desperate
language how badly he needed me to make
only fan
it was probably a joke but i mean i i
wasn't sure
uh while you were praying partying he
studied the
blade and podcasting i'm not very good
at podcasting or blade so
maybe i should have just parted
that's awesome though i love the whole
all the sword imagery it's so sick
this one someone just goofing on me here
my weird ass my weird ass my loving
girlfriend
a couple times i don't know why they
made your arms tiny yeah
just really funny i have no idea why
they did that but it looked so funny
i know and it got and it was like very
well received
i don't think there's any reasoning to
it it's pretty funny i agree
it's i don't know why what is it does it
look like
you get maybe you get the way you're
standing like a dinosaur
right and i have little t-rex paws
this one i loved i knew he looked like i
said he looked like
sashquash bigfoot on the water
and it's totally true look at the
posture is exactly the same it's so
awesome
so there you have it the memes have been
strong you know usually when we do these
meme segments i'm like oh [ __ ] this [ __ ]
this [ __ ] this but
these are all good so keep it up guys
also if you've gone over to the h3
podcast at discord available members
only there's a hell
of a lot of good conversation there
sorry guys so many i just i've been
chugging this coca-cola
because i've just been very stressed
about the whole
everything happening this morning can
you switch to water
no i mean chug in the water um
smat dude smash mouth
smash mouth yes uh shrek shrek mouth
you know shrek kind of like almost you
could say they made smash mouth which is
probably true they put them on the map
somewhat that's not true they were they
were popular yeah they were big
but like they immortalized smash mouth
i but also they ruined minimized
yeah because it's just ramified
they've been mummified they've been
mummified in a mummification
anyway you guys probably heard sturgis
motorcycle rally in america
10 day festival with an estimated 200
ethan estimated to attract 250 000
motorcycle enthusiasts
all around the country where sturgis
stan
oh south dakota
is that the better dakota um
i don't have a strong opinion i think
south dakota has rushmore
so we like are they at least
well they at least have something i
don't think there's really much
to north dakota but i apologize for
north dakota
yeah i mean i could see that for saying
that if that's uh if that's upsetting to
you
so anyway 250 000 are in south dakota
the festival features motorcycle shows a
roller derby
drag race and poker tournaments etc
nobody's wearing masks they are
encouraging people to wear masks
not uh requiring it and so of course
nobody there is wearing masks
social distancing et cetera and
they have the lineup band the headliner
is smash mouth
apparently they just have a bunch of
really kind of a bad lineup of bands but
including also um
drawing pool who is famous for the song
let the bodies hit the floor
which i thought was apt
drawing pool what did i say
drawing pool dry what are you saying
drawing
drawing is in a drowning pool though i'm
reading what you
wrote it's it's spelled drawing pull
down
oh it is drawing it's it's drowning
well somebody one of you guys wrote the
name of the band
for me it's drowning pool it's just it's
drowning pool so who wrote it
uh i don't know and maybe it was me
maybe it's a type of i think i i don't
think that they're
as far as i know there's no band name
drawing pools okay
who wrote drawing pool i don't know i'm
not looking at the doctor
i remember even seeing your ass in the
document writing that
called out was it you oh my god
no oh all right rip like grace hanson
do i need to bring back chris hanson
just remember your ass is
going to jail for some serious crimes is
this what he's going to sit me down for
is he
stealing drowning i can't believe you're
not going to own that zach
i didn't i didn't do it i swear to god i
think i think it might have been me
but um but that would have been a typo
if it was you dan
that's unforgivable because you're the
one that called me out for it well i
didn't
it wasn't intentional hold on you called
me out for it you [ __ ]
set me up what the hell
that's such [ __ ]
yeah i just pulled it up there the my
original doc and
it does saying drawing pool so that's
that's my bad
oh my god i'm gonna blame autocorrect
for that one no all right
as soon as you said it i knew that was
wrong well why how are you blaming
drowning is a word why would auto
operate
why would they change it to drawing if
drowning is a typo and it just
auto-corrected it too
i don't know how these things work all
right all right i don't know
so excellent all right i know is who's
going to be addressed on the next cameo
do you think do you think i'm on the
chopping block yeah that's very
interesting point
[Laughter]
yeah okay so drowning pool
is going to be performing let the bodies
hit the floor
which is awesome yeah considering
um here when you see the footage of the
people that are attending watch this
it's just a bunch of like let's say put
this politely
oh there's a bunch of bikers that's no
no it's gonna be more specific
uh i guess they're not i was good
there's a lot of fat
people there i don't see many fat people
here but no actually not
i mean yeah but like i mean this is
awesome you're in the middle of a
pandemic
no literally not one mask in sight
everyone passed together and then
someone's singing let the bodies hit the
[ __ ]
it's so awesome let the parties hit the
floor
let
and then everybody's singing along and
screaming it's like spitting on each
other it's
awesome i mean it's hilariously ironic
you know if it wasn't sad but what can
you do at a certain point these people
just want to die
yeah or die free i guess they say i'd
rather
these are i love these people man they
think that wearing a mask
is tear asking people to wear a mask
is tyranny it's really highlighting just
this whole concept of freedom here in
america
like it's fine like freedom is one thing
but
you can also follow
science and the rules either can i ask
you something
the same people i'm making a
generalization so
take this for for what it is but it's
not to me
that the same people who complain that
wearing masks
is tyranny don't say [ __ ] when police
pull up in plain clothes
and throw people in unmarked vans um you
just
that's just the talking points on tv no
but like i mean
that seems way more man
yeah jake paul is like oof
but don't you think there's something
overlapping bro
that's way scarier like you said that is
a generalization though and there
i am i'm sure there are some that are
anti-mass that are also anti-police
brutality i think most liberty
brutality dance is having the stance
that you're not even talking about
police brutality i'm talking about
pulling up an un
marked uniforms throwing people in
unmarked vans and
and taking off how many people have you
asked what their opinion is on that
i would venture to say well i'm just i'm
saying i've seen a lot more people
complaining about masks being a sign of
tyranny
than being thrown in an unmarked van and
being taken off
that's because they're being asked to
wear a mask versus the other thing they
don't happen well let's start
let's start scooping people up and see
if they object
i think i think a principled libertarian
would uh would hold those two positions
that you're
that you're stating no masks and
and again no kidnappings no government
sanction kidnapping theoretically uh
yeah they would they would be very
against [ __ ] yes good good good
i love it trump loves whoosh does he
love
i said i love it okay all right i won't
ask for clarification i want to push
we have the president on the line here
nobody likes me
that's not true there's plenty of people
that like you don't be hard on yourself
all right we're probably at break time
uh though i don't know if you let me
finish this story um
so smash so they're gonna be reading uh
somebody once told me that dude
next to me has coveted and he gonna
cough in my face
well he's breathing kind of heavy and
soon he'll be on a ventilator
and it won't be long before he's dead
well the cases start coming in they
don't stop coming
the hospitals are packed and people
start running they come to
searches just to have some fun but then
they come live and they leave
dead and they leave dead that's dumb
so much to do but so many need to die
before we start wearing masks
you'll never know if you don't go to
sturgis you'll never know if you don't
die
insurgents hey now
you've got kovid hanging out
you've got kovid but don't say that
you get the idea i think it's a good
remix we started really strong and it
was very impressive yeah
it was [ __ ] dope first of all
pretty good man we kind of lost steam
there at the end
well it's hard to keep that up hey now
you got covered come spread
oh that sprays is covered
only shooting only shoot what do they
call it um
droplet yeah droplets only shooting
respiratory
droplets in the air
don't breathe because it's in the air
sunshine disinfects but
not from the hair
because yeah i'm
[Applause]
[Music]
anything else oh yeah oh yeah you're
gonna like this ela um
here's smash mouth doing their headline
listen this is him
[Music]
is he gonna get down and mingle with the
crowd oh that's a really
good that's a really good question
because wait i'll read there's actually
something related to that
because they're up there on the stage
keeping six feet so listen to this
yeah he said we're all together tonight
[ __ ] that covered ship
yeah tonight until tomorrow people just
can't breathe
so listen to this the band's manager
quickly tried to do damage control in a
statement to a billboard he said
everything backstage was sanitized the
band has their own covet addendum to the
rider as well
and the promoter and venue adhere to all
of our requests
so their damage control is we were safe
up on the stage
but all the plebs down in on there [ __ ]
over to that
but we're safe i mean that's crazy
[ __ ] that coverage yeah [ __ ] you guys
too
[ __ ] that [ __ ] whoa whoa whoa whoa not
too close
not too close it's in our rider all
staff members must maintain 20 feet from
us
we spent endless out this is to
continuing the quote from their manager
we spent endless hours advancing this
event to make sure it was pulled off as
safely as possible and we are very happy
with the outcome really look at this wow
this is uh this is a view from the stage
smash mouth what's safe about this
the smash mouth organization is taking
this pandemic very seriously and has
taken measures to keep our band crew
and fans as safe as possible during this
time yeah i think that would just mean
not showing up to this
or at the very least wear a mask
instead of saying [ __ ] cover be like
guys please put on your masks
well it should be required yeah yeah but
this is america it would be too round
uh from what i was reading it it
actually was required at the event but
um
obviously just nobody did it and what
are you going to say wait i heard it was
optional
i read that it was optional on their on
i don't
i read differently well regardless it
doesn't matter you either enforce it or
you don't
yeah exactly i just find it incredible
because like we're here i guess living
in a bubble it's hard to to
really you know realize how vast and how
many different kinds of people are in
this country
but it's just incredibly that nobody not
even one person in the sea of people is
like
concerned i mean we just drove to
newport beach and no one was concerned
there either there were some people but
the majority were not wearing masks it
was like
five percent maybe yeah but this is a
huge gathering i
would expect to see i guess anyone
that's really concerned just wouldn't go
right you know yeah they were estimating
a quarter of a million people
uh arriving according to that article
but i'd be curious how many
actually showed up like if the turnout
was suppressed
that does not look like a quarter
million but well it's just one
yeah or whatever yeah and it's a 10-day
event so
um hey now oh um
so let's see here the hospital's got 50
ventilators and there's only five
left to spare hey now
you need a ventilator but we're getting
short so
hurry hey now you need a ventilator
or you can't breathe so you'll nah it's
not that funny
yeah it's getting worse and worse [ __ ]
does anyone else want to try
i'll leave it in the car you guys
leaving me in the trenches here i was
grooving to that
see zach's the best all right let's go
to a quick commercial break
and it is quick i'm telling you we don't
have any ads left teddy fresh is being
canceled
i mean it's kind of bleak here on the h3
come on such a downer jimmy well i'm
just being honest i mean [ __ ] is [ __ ]
dude
it's just awful
chris hansen you know how much it costs
for that chris hanson clip was it like
300 bucks dan
i don't think oh no chris hanson was
mega cheap yeah this was like
50 bucks there were some other ones that
that
that turned us down that were extremely
expensive yeah actually we put an order
out for somebody i don't want to give
out the name yet because i want to be
surprised but he was like 350 right
uh yeah it was something like that yeah
that'll be great though if it pays off
but we got chris hanson to basically say
i will
make fake charges against you
for 50 bucks or whatever it was maybe it
was like so
good no that was great chris hanson dude
the fact that you get chris hanson to
threaten anyone you want
for 50 bucks is like the brave new world
like
is like uh how do you say it's the
dystopian future that we all want to
to have although dystopian is inherently
bad isn't it it's a utopian future
sure let's have a quick break and when
we come back
we're going to talk about uh
so so so so so so much great stuff ellen
i want this
ellen do you know that ellen forbid her
interns to look at her
i always find that so interesting so i
put together a whole list of celebrities
that don't allow their employees to look
at them
i of course i'm on the top of that i was
gonna say you're on the list yeah
all right we'll be right back
i got to be honest my underwear drawer
before i found myandes was an
embarrassing disaster
and i'm going to be honest with you guys
again i've carried around the same
underwear
for decades and you get to the point
where the underwear just gets crusty
it starts to disintegrate you ever had
underwear for so long it just
disintegrates
there's literally just holes not tears
like
holes where the fabric has disintegrated
you know
have you ever have you ever owned
underwear that long is that like i have
seen that
i probably have seen it
on near underwear happening i know what
you're talking about yeah
well it's embarrassing and it's not fun
but that's what me undies is
is that every time you open your drawer
it's fun it's exciting you start your
day you take the shower you open your
underwear drawer
boom you get excited because not only do
you have beautiful designs
it's lush it's soft it's caressing it's
wonderful
your it makes your day better knowing
that you're gonna have to see beautiful
fabrics they're gonna
nestle up on your ass crack balls and
penis
and let's be honest that's kind of the
most important stuff
to treat well it's not just for guys too
well yeah and you have a butt all in a
vagina
yeah that's important too uh listen me
undies is
serious about softness they're super
serious
they scoured the earth for the softest
fabric known to man
it all starts with sustainably sourced
beechwood trees that magically turn from
pulp
to yarn to undies you can keep your
undies
drawer stocked with me undies
memberships a subscription that sends
new pairs
right to your door plus you get
site-wide savings
and exclusive sales me undies has a
great offer for our listeners
for any first time purchase you get 15
off and free shipping it's a no-brainer
especially considering you have a 100
satisfaction guarantee that's means if
you don't love the undies if they're not
perfectly comfortable
forget it send it get your money back
forget about it so
to get 15 off your first order free
shipping
and 100 satisfaction guaranteed go to
meundies.com
h3 that's meundies.com h3
welcome back everybody we i've come to
this point in the episode we're
gonna be talking about ellen
ellen is the per one of those people
that just gets one name
thoughts on that incorrect
ellen degeneres no but people call her
ellen it's just like oh
oh i know who you're talking about ellen
you don't have to say
by the way her name is ellen the
degenerate
pretty good right um
i don't know this statement is not that
great so
bono edge
i don't think that's equivalent ellen
it's alan degeneres
i guess but like who else gets that
recognition by just their first name
name one person you say their first name
and they get
that immediate recognition one first
name
howard no howard does not have that
zach i'm sorry i think so
ellen yeah people would say stern yeah
people say stern
every every like stern fan i meet like
when you bring me mentioned john
go on the street and be like you know
howard
and they'll be like whoo no they're
gonna be all like how would you go on
the street
i'd say ellen people like yeah ellen
there's only one ellen
we all know who ellen is fair enough
it's a phenomenon that i think
is is worth the you know raising
it's okay obama
see that's that's how about hey i've got
a good one
go ahead gila um mm-hmm
only here though there's a lot
that's right yeah it's like a super
common name yeah you say that here
though
but here you don't know it so i'm going
to be like what and you we have to get
you more famous i'm the only one because
if you go on the street
a very unique name here i found it on
that you are the only one that's pretty
cool
does it feel cool to come here and b
feel more unique and the name wise
definitely i don't hate my name here in
israel i feel like
how would you describe how would you
compare because in israel ila is almost
like the deborah or something
what would i compare i only say deborah
because all of my friends
i only say that why are you gonna do
that can i explain
because all of my friends growing up
like all of their moms was named deborah
but why are you
why am i a mom i'm just saying it's a
common name
there's no meaning but what was your
friend's
common name you know why are you looking
at the amanda
i don't know lots of amanda's growing up
yeah ashley
yeah it's like that yeah are we done
we're gonna argue today about everything
ellen so anyway
ellen she's been in the news as you guys
know
there's kind of two parallel distinct
situations going on with ellen
um one is that the workplace
on the ellen show what is it her name
is just the ellen show what is it called
ellen show yeah
i think it's the ellen show yeah ellen's
show what is the official name
i think it might even just be ellen no
it's the ellen degeneres
show oh for real yeah wait hold on
the ellen degeneres the degenerate show
you know what i found out when uh
researching this we can't get the
simplest
no but what i said is true
she's still ellen
i thought her show was just called ellen
i thought it was just
helen well it's not no it's not it's
called the ellen degeneres show
i think they should rebrand though
i'm surprised it's called the ellen
degeneres show aren't you
no i thought it was because people
always just say i'm going on ellen
they don't want that i swear they do
they say
they do i'm going on ellen
okay i don't know i've said alan so many
times it's a losing
meaning okay so the ellen d can i may i
call it ellen for the purpose of trying
to explain the story because i say the
whole name
the ellen degeneres shows a lot to take
in
what is the origin what does degeneres
mean where is that from
i it's a weird name it's a weird name
degeneres
what's the origin of that somebody find
out quick
zack's working on it considering he's
typing away ellen he's crunching the
numbers right now it's just the last
name
isn't it degeneres i never met another
degeneres
to be honest i thought it was called the
ellen show thank you
ian who usually contradicts me on
every single point supports me on this
one the generous is french
okay yeah i should have guessed it can
you pronounce can you pronounce it in
french de generi
did you read the phonetics or was you
disgusting no that was just me doing a
friendship
degeneres did you know that her brother
was a correspondent on the daily show
for years
oh no i didn't let me see a picture of
her brother sam's vance degeneres
and he was like one of the og ones in
like the early 2000s when
jon stewart was first i wonder if he's a
better show
that his sister made it and he didn't
i don't even recognize him huh i've
never seen him you think she you think
when you're that rich you just kick
down money to your family they look
i mean you definitely can see that
they're siblings yeah wow definitely
look at that i actually do i remember
him
i mean vaguely it was a long time ago
that he was on the daily show but i
remember he was one of the
correspondents
with uh you know stephen colbert and
corel in that era
do they both just have like whatever
skin tightening cosmetic surgery
because about their faces look a little
tight his more so
anyway she's worth about half a billion
dollars you think she just kicks down
that's a good question about any any
problem
millionaire you probably have to
handsome guy this is a much better photo
don't you think um than this one
looks like like a little bit like a
vampire in that
one yeah okay
vampire energy there anyway this is like
let's get to that this whole episode uh
lynn ellen
so it's a toxic workplace environment
and then the other layer is that ellen
herself
is a rude mean person so we're going to
talk about
these two issues separately if that's
okay with you ela yeah i think
the teddy fresh controversy really got
to either broke her mind
first of all ellen's show is being
accused of being a toxic
workplace what does that mean
one former black employee claimed that a
main writer once told her
i'm sorry i only know the names of the
white people who work here
which is like so comically insane and
embracist that it's hard to believe
someone could even say that frankly yeah
i'm sorry i only know the names of the
white people that work here
that's crazy bro but that's what this uh
that's what this person told the
reporter from buzzfeed
well they wrote the current and former
workers faced intimidation tactics and
racism
in other cases boys had in other cases
that i literally said employees
and you always said tax sticks employees
ela
in other cases employees had to struggle
to get necessary time off listen to this
one employee had to request time off
after getting into a car accident
and having two family deaths within a
year
they claimed that each request was a
battle with
supervisors in hr in another case an
employee took a month of medical leave
to go to a mental health facility after
a suicide attempt
when that employee returned to set they
learned their position was being
eliminated
that's pretty good yeah sounds kind of
similar to uh
no way the whole no not funny ethan
suicide attempt not joke about that i
was gonna make a joke about like
ian breaking his foot and we tried to
fire him but um
we he got hr involved
i'm hr by the way
is that a conflict of interest
also there's been lots of sexual assault
allegations that i don't even want to
read because i actually need the revenue
desperately on this
on our podcast so i'm not going to read
them but
they're really really gross and heinous
kind of typical harvey weinstein type of
stuff from the executive purdue
producers what the hell
um yeah so that's kind of i mean
that that's actually the big part of
that allegation of the toxic workplace
so if you're interested in
those kinds of allegations apparently
all kinds of just like really gross
statements like
um some producer told
and a black employee oh wow you both
have box braids i hope we don't get you
confused
like i guess about two black people
i'm wondering if that could have been
misunderstood
i don't really see it like if it was
just like that was the same producer
with the other
uh no oh it's the same producer i think
so when i
because i saw that too someone that made
the other comment about uh not knowing
the names of black employees because
i could see that maybe them just being
like oh you guys have the same haircut
oh we don't get you confused but like
i'm just trying to give them a benefit
yeah perhaps but once you combine it
with
with the other stuff it's well once you
tell someone yeah
once you tell someone i only remember
white people's names
yeah that one is that one's a real
heinous that one i cannot
uh when the sexual assault ones um from
what i know
stood reading it is uh was corroborated
by like
a bill yeah it was like three dozen
employees all said yeah that happened so
it's like not just
a couple people it's like yeah everybody
that works on the show is like yeah that
happened that's a good point
dan the person who wrote the article was
like 36
different employees corroborated these
stories and then the next line is like
the producers deny it it's like you
can't i mean
that's like everybody that ever worked
on the show
36 that's everybody
yeah so then that's part one
part two is that ellen is a dick
uh the daily beast isn't that ben
shapiro's um
or is that no that's a daily caller
there's a lot of daily somethings out
there yeah it's confusing these two yeah
the beast the daily beast published a
story detailing accounts for many former
employees
and encounters with her such as ellen
refusing to make eye contact with
interns
ellen almost getting a waitress fired
for having a chipped
nail wait what yes what does that mean
apparently the waitress had a chipped
nail and ellen
tried to get her fired look
i i just looked it up it was actually
daily wire so it's another another
daily i'm gonna make a uh newspaper
called the daily daily
it probably already exists the daily
daily
maybe just take out the and replace it
with daily
daily daily daily daily schmutz
so i know i don't quite understand why
would you be offended by someone having
a chip now but i'm not ellen yeah why
would you
it's like oh i can't imagine what
well i would hate to have to see that if
someone was serving me food
it's like you don't want to see that
i don't know i'm just trying to use my
imagination
i think i did actually see some comments
to that effect though uh if you're at a
nice restaurant
okay imagine this i'm just trying to
understand imagine you're out i wouldn't
know this
would you even look at the nail imagine
you're at a
three star michelin restaurant
world renown thousand dollars per head
you get you're waiting here's this
beautiful plate
of food and then what do you see
a chip now as they're serving i would
talk
and that's why yeah that's what i had in
mind and then she probably went to the
manager and was like
it's like a larry david moment just want
to say
the food was good chip nail
i don't think it's worth bringing out of
course
it's crazy it's insane i'm just trying
to imagine that even the situation how
it occurs
yeah of course it's the craziest thing i
ever heard
she fired a former head writer karen
kilgraf karen for refusing to cross the
picket line during the 2008 rider strike
well that's douchey
that's really douchey refusing to what
so there was a rider strike in hollywood
and uh that her head one of her head
riders
refused to go into work because she was
in solidarity with her
uh union and so ellen fired her
she for load a large chunk of her crew
that sounds kind of illegal
like that are you allowed to protest
i don't know i mean they haven't i'm not
really i'm not really sure but
the labor laws in hollywood and when it
comes to the unions is incredibly
complicated
there may have been they may have found
some loopholes some other way of letting
them go
uh yeah yeah a lot of politics
that kind of stuff uh during covet she
furloughed
a large chunk of her crew during the
crisis
and instead hired non-union outfit to
run the tech
for at-home broadcast that's so dirty
bro
why'd you why'd you do them so dirty
like that
i mean she's worth half a billion
dollars like i mean how much does it
cost to keep those people on payroll for
mm-hmm even a year
not even a 100 billion networks why are
these networks so [ __ ]
cheap ass that they can't float these
people for a minute
um and then
those who did stay on were told their
pay would be cut by
sixty percent and have reduced hours
well the reduced hours i understand
because there's not much work but why
cut their pay 60
by the way and then ellen's net worth is
estimated between 300 and 500 million
dollars
yeah that's just lame you would think
that also
just i don't know it sounds like she
comes from
not an easy way uh
making it when she came out as gay she
had a hard time
yeah and she kind of had to like start
over so it sounds like
someone that would have a little more
empathy for people but
apparently not i mean as business owners
that was something that we definitely
didn't would never
consider doing this stuff
the covid stuff yeah the not looking me
in the eyes is obviously something
like i totally get that standard
operating procedure right there
the last time zach looked me in the eyes
i told him to go home stay home for two
weeks and i cut his pay by
60 he put the fear
you guys can you guys can speak with
authority that you've been uh you've
been really good to us during this whole
crisis
thank you i've been waiting for you to
say that a million percent yeah
not to blow you too hard or anything but
uh but yeah no we're
we're grateful we know this is a tough
time and you you there
we've never had any uh fear of getting
laid off or furloughed or anything so
well you you shouldn't because you guys
won't you guys ain't going anywhere
except zach people don't subscribe
and if and i'm not super it's okay not
having to look you in the eyes
as well yeah we don't really live with
it yeah yeah i know you're not good at
with eye contact anyway and so i figured
she's doing you a favor
you know it's because i'm always looking
at my slick shoes
ian what do you think about those new
yeezys the white eggshell oh god
please tell me that you hate it let me
pull that up you know he doesn't you
know he does wait hold on hold on let me
pull up some people know we're talking
have you seen it then yeah we were
talking about it the other day oh
you guys already talked about it
hold on how is it possible where are
they i can't even find them what are
they called ian
just say alien looking easy put him on
his
twitter uh they were still up as of
yesterday because we were just talking
ian what do you know what they're called
of course he knows well tell me then
he's muted i don't think he realizes
he's muted
oh oh yeah can you hear me yeah yeah
it's with the basketball player derek
rose okay search derrick rose easy okay
are those the buzz this is the [ __ ] this
is the worst thing i've ever no way do
you like this
here let me show this
let me pull them up on my end too i need
a refresher
i don't believe you here i just don't
here it is on twitter
so ian you didn't say do you like these
um it looks like packing peanuts as a
shoe
they're they're kind of slick oh my god
those are the opposite of flick i mean
you could say a lot of things about that
shoe but that
that's not slick it's kind of slick
how much are they how do i get one i
kind of want to try it
there's there's another one too that he
tweeted that in my opinion is even worse
really i don't know if you saw that no
let me just click his twitter i thought
this one was
tweeting like crazy uh so here's this
if you keep scrolling i think it wasn't
too much further down oh this one the
yellow one
uh no although i mean that one i don't
know
what got my band on that one too but
it's back to this now keep going wow
i'm gonna show ian's background real
quick there you go
this that's a sketch no you'll know it
when you see it just keep scrolling it's
coming it's coming there there
oh oh no i think the other one i think
that one is worth it yeah
okay because this one is more of like a
pretty wearable
it's like slippers i mean
so is there there's no info about price
or anything on these
no well yeah i think it was just there
might just be concepts
well i will say it's a real i mean i've
never seen a shoe like that i don't know
if that's a good thing or not but
it's like wearing a giant tooth come on
who wouldn't want to wear it
kind of toothy that's gross like a shark
tooth i guess
i guess it looks more like a like an
invertebrate of a prehistoric
like sea animal that you'll find in a
box see the picture
like when you see um like architecture
projects like
in college an architecture student
that would be like their that would be
their prototype what they wanted the
building that they would make
yeah they're like trying you're trying
so hard to
be original and it is original but for a
reason because it's a bad idea
you know what i mean show yeah show this
look here yeah
look look at what it looks like with
someone wearing it
please no it's my background please tell
me that do you see this
[Applause]
this looks so stupid it's so clunky
that's not i mean you call that you
can't call that slick bro
if you're looking is it the uh the girl
with the shoe on and the white sweater
yeah no it's just legs it's from the
same set of the
photos that you have as your background
because she's wearing the same blue
leggings
blue like so i think a little context i
think she's wearing
a size she put in her bio like i'm
wearing a size 12 or 13.
i think just like as a goof
okay how did she get her where do we get
those why are we guys
these are designed for this basketball
player derrick rose this is going to be
the derrick rose shoe he's going to wear
those while he plays
i don't know if i don't know i i don't
think those will be court
legal but i don't know they look oh yeah
i see yeah she's wearing like that's his
wife yeah
yeah yeah that's his wife so who's this
girl why is she getting a pair of wife
oh it's his wife sorry i don't yeah i
should be listening more
they look kind of dope i'm not gonna lie
like here god
come on no you've got to give it some
points
if someone walked by with those on
that's like a head-turning
yeah but ian if you walked by with a
swastika on your forehead i'd also turn
my head
i think that's a bit of a different
situation but i'm just saying like if
your only point is that it's
yeah turning isn't always good yeah
i'm sorry but i do not like it i don't
like it
i give points for uniqueness try hard uh
like howard hughes at the end of his
life when he's all crazy
and he would wear uh like those giant
like tissue boxes on his feet
you were seeing the pictures of him well
we were talking about something about
ellen i don't know
okay so back to ellen um
oh actually some actors even went on the
record and were like yeah ellen's a
[ __ ]
it's crazy because you don't really see
that but this dude from everybody loves
raymond
really this big the tall dude who played
raymond's brother
yeah he just strips slammed her
he goes sorry but it comes from the top
no and then he tags the show no more
than one who were treated horribly by
her it's common knowledge
the generous sends emotional apology to
staff you notice how he called her
wait that was a quote he said common
knowledge his tweet ended there
they did some kind of weird like old
people facebook where
that's the title of the article
and i don't know how that got in his
tweet
cabish all right
and then lee uh leah thompson who's also
a famous actress
went ahead and slam dunked her uh
brat oh this article about the tweet we
just read brad garrett claims
mistreatment by ellen is common
knowledge
and then lee thompson comes underneath
and says true
true story it is that's
they're kind of b-list celebrities
though to be honest and that's probably
why they don't care to speak up
right and it's right right right right
it's worth pointing out the accusation
is that
well i guess we'll get there maybe jump
in the gun but like a-listers all say
she's nice of course but right exactly
that's
right yeah the people they're like
people like tom hanks says she's
like yeah of course you know she's she's
[ __ ] giving tom hanks a hand job when
he rolls around
i guess that's always the problem when
you're like well this person is nice to
me
so there must be nine i didn't know that
they raped
a hundred i didn't know that bill cosby
was always a nice yeah it's like well
yeah it doesn't mean doesn't that
in itself isn't evidence anyway i'm not
accusing her of anything except being an
[ __ ] which by the way isn't a crime
let's keep this in in uh well her
producers seem to have
have been doing much worse things than
being [ __ ]
the racist comments though that's pretty
talkative yeah
the environment too yeah dude
i i'm assuming that she kind of just
shows up and leaves
you know what i mean but but obviously
it's her responsibility to make sure
that people are
having a safe work environment but
anyway i
got fascinated by
well i guess i should mention this first
uh there's a whole
movement to make eric allen eric andre
not to change the show name or anything
just to make
eric ellen keep the name the same
just replace him place her with him
make eric ellen i like amazing
i'd watch that amazing i wonder what
that would do for the ratings
okay but i got i got fascinated by this
concept of these celebrities who don't
allow people to look
at them in the eye yeah and so we did
some research
of um of celebrities who
apparently also have this reputation
katy perry now what now where did you
get the info on this stuff zach what
about katy perry
um it was just various websites you know
people explaining stories
people in the food industry saying
they've come into the restaurant
blog posts stuff like that and they're
instructed not to look at them or what
well it's just stories from it like oh i
couldn't even look her in the eye
she looked she yelled at me for looking
her in the eye stuff like that
like wow
are you supposed to know not to look
mega celebrities in the eye
it's such a weird concept yeah
okay so katy perry beyonce
jlo we got an excerpt here um the
actress and singer jennifer lopez is
supposedly one
super cheapskate recently radar online
has posted that an anonymous source has
revealed that lopez pays minimum wage to
her employees
as a result her staff have started
calling lopez
payload instead of jlo
behind her back oh my god not only does
lopez pay her employees an extremely low
wage
but she also expects them to work really
hard well it sounds like she should
probably just get a new job
not that they're that easy to find but
uh that's hilarious payload the thing is
when you're that rich and famous you
gotta pay people good because they'll
just goof on you
like what's that extra five dollars an
hour to jlo you know what i mean
payload payload is the best yeah that's
just that's so amateur it's like
if you're rich and famous you gotta
leave big tips
you gotta pay people more it's just it's
just not worth it
to to be a cheapo mm-hmm
yeah i think some people getting this uh
twisted like
i worked hard for my money that doesn't
mean that
what do i got to change my behavior now
that i'm rich yeah
i'm i'm still a person i'm sorry but
this was a 10
mac no we always tip fat when we go out
now
and i'm not we're not even that famous
but if they know me if they know who we
are
i don't want them to be like yo ethan
listen you don't want to be a payload i
don't want to be pale
klein means small so
yeah it's not really can't really play
on words in that it's just penis jokes
and they're true
sylvester stallone nick uh nicole kidman
i mean these are just names really
there's no information so what can you
say but mariah carey has been known to
require her staff members
walk backwards in her presence just to
make sure they don't show their backs to
her
something she's like the king of england
that was like the thing yeah
she says wait so that's the opposite of
not making an eye contact
she says something she considers to be
deeply disrespectful is that
[ __ ] is that for real zack uh
according to
these websites it's a gossip website we
take all of this with the greatness
yeah mariah carey requires staff to exit
rooms
back that was literally the thing in
like for like english kings like you you
couldn't turn your back to them you had
to like back out of the room
and bow i believe it coming from her
mariah is pretty wild kanye
uh when kanye is performing or making an
appearance on tv
he demands that the carpet is in his
dressing room be ironed
demands the carpet in his dressing room
be iron what ian have you heard that
way but that sense he says
if there's a carpet in his dressing room
he demands that it be ironed
how do you iron a car
maybe from the back i don't know maybe
we've never maybe we don't know because
we've never tried it maybe it's great
you're walking on these like on iron
carpets here
like a bunch of crispy carpet losers
ariana grande that pop
diva has a pretty outrageous request
that she makes of anyone whom she
deems fit enough to actually carry it
out believe it or not she prefers to be
carried around from place
is that why i know what is this stupid i
don't believe
any of this these are gossip websites
this is what you want this is not what i
wanted
i said i wanted i just wanted uh to hear
all the rumors of celebs
i mean look in their eyes this is that
this
let me read this again zach can you tell
me if this sounds uh real
ariana request that people carry
believe it or not she prefers to be
carried around from place to place
ariata claims that the shoes she wears
are too tough on her feet
so she prefers to be carried
i got a little story from a friend of
mine that worked
i don't want to give too many details
just to not get him in trouble he told
me in confidence but
he worked on a on a very popular
television program
and the uh lead actor of the show one
time
uh got upset because he got in his eye
line
essentially which is something that it's
not it's not
looking them in the eye but it's like
actors sometimes get very upset about
that because they find it distracting if
like a pa or somebody is is in their eye
line
but this guy got so mad he picked up a
chair and
threw it violently at my friend yeah
yeah um and yeah i mean that's what he
told me that's an
apparently true story well i
find it useful hearing it firsthand
because otherwise
i i would be hesitant to even believe
stuff like that
this would technically be like third
hand but may well maybe your friend
shouldn't have been in his eye line
is it like let me ask you this is it
like a really cheesy kind of show or was
it like
oh he was doing a really dramatic
intense moment
um well i guess that would be a matter
of opinion of how you feel about the
show i really don't
i don't want to say too much more for
giving away but um it it was a very
popular show like
i would say for years was a a top 10
rated show
on network television so big big star so
is a big moment
yeah well uh aria according to zach
ariana grande
uh demands to be carried from place to
place
i didn't come up with this ring and then
rihanna
zack says it is said that rihanna
doesn't even bother speaking to her
staff
an anonymous source revealed that
rihanna doesn't talk to
any of the hired help apparently rihanna
also falls asleep when she is getting
her makeup done this is so
stupid what do you mean that she doesn't
talk to her staff how do they
communicate
what does she expect telepathy i don't
understand
i have assistance or something i don't
know well okay she delegates
yeah i mean yeah it sounds like this is
a bunch of tabloid rags so who knows
i'm sorry there's not a new york times
article on this
i guess
sources on this washington post new york
times
[Laughter]
what website did you get this from i'm
just curious [ __ ] i forgot
the name daily crap
the daily [ __ ]
oh this one says about ian that uh the
celebrity known as ian
the salaried employee makes his
co-workers um
uh speaking uh listen to jesus
on repeat was going on vulgar he's done
that to me repeatedly apparently ethan
klein of the h3 podcast
makes his employees get on their knees
and bow to him before they enter a room
that one's true that one i can't believe
bow to me kylie
jen okay we're moving on thank you
everybody thank you zach for the
research it was fun
the one that i really have a hard time
believing is the aria grande one
personally
i've just heard crazier [ __ ] it doesn't
she might have a weird feet thing where
like people are under her feet she
doesn't want to [ __ ] up her feet
maybe it happened once when she was
wearing
like a really crazy costume for a show
concert
that's something so she was like can you
carry being carried
and then everyone's like she she
requires to be careful
i mean i see her walking i've seen her
walk in
i mean i've seen it yeah
i can say from uh from firsthand
experience
well whatever what go ahead when i was a
waiter
years ago uh uh i worked at a restaurant
that that had a
decent amount of celebrity traffic we
had some pretty famous people come
through
and um and you know they the staff we
they would get reputations for which
ones were good tippers and which ones
weren't
and um this was a long time this was
literally a decade ago go ahead
but justin bieber bad tipper
that is such what a dumb ass how much he
tipped
like like normal or like even worse than
normal
15 which isn't bad i mean that that
most people consider that a standard tip
but like you said most celebrities do
tip pretty fat and so it was notable
that he
was 15 percent when you're justin bieber
yeah well
he was pretty young though i mean this
is a decade ago he was like probably
changed a lot
yeah so i don't know if that is still
the case i guess when you're a kid i
mean
yeah i wouldn't don't really understand
tipping or the significance
i can i can give them a pass you know
who did tip well though i'll give props
to
who came in a lot was uh khloe
kardashian
wow and uh well i think at the time
yeah they would come in as a couple a
lot they 30
like good fat tip every time wow see for
me i'm thinking like
i'm thinking like it depends on the bill
because sometimes
when you spend a lot of money like it
hurts but like i'm thinking like 50
usually i mean that's that's crazy fat
you don't tip 50
yeah i do you're trying to tweet your
own
i think so if we go out and spend 50
bucks i'll leave like a 20
25. okay but the thing is sometimes
i mean if you go out and spend like 500
then right i'm not leaving 250.
yeah that's maybe 200 i believe 20
is always i would leave 200 on a 500.
well you're a great tipper then i i
agree thank you
that seems a little questionable
dude on 500. honestly we haven't been
out for so long
that oh and but i'm the one that always
orders food and i'm always
i leave you are the one that tips look
at the history
i have no way to look it up i always
leave
people by the way since covet yeah it's
on my phone
you mean on seamless yeah and stuff like
that yeah on covid since govis started
and i'm like these guys are these are
the uh
you know the frontline workers right so
i always make a point
of giving them
i think because usually when you order
it's cheap so it's like
i i think i always give them like
at least 20 bucks for the delivery
that's very generous and i'm making it
sound like i'm a [ __ ]
someone who's gonna pull up every seat
then they're gonna be like
somebody in the audience has made a
delivery i'm telling you i'm get i'm
just
we're ordering food all the time i'm
like 20 20 20.
i just don't like making a statement
like that that someone could
rebuttal very easily do you think
someone's gonna go online and try to
refute me
well you can say like you're you're
trying to ethan only
actually i have ethan only gave me eight
bucks
can you skip on the tip if uh if if
they're like super late or if they're
like well
so interestingly enough on seamless
which is really bizarre you tip before
the food ride right that's true
but on postmates i will i'll i tip good
no matter what
i don't care what happens and usually i
don't open it until a few days later and
i don't even remember
you know i believe you you you
mike mike just cut out you uh you you've
you've proven to be very uh generous
with tips i we've gone out to
eat at restaurants and stuff and i've
seen it so thank you
dan i'll back you up on this one i'm not
usually the one that you wish
that um don't you wish that
tipping just wasn't an issue of course
yeah they should pay
it's just employees of course well
horrible not really fair to even
well that's it's a pretty uniquely
american thing no
like the the culture in america the the
whole experience in america i don't have
the same in israel
really i think you i think israel is
also unique i mean all of europe
yeah i think in europe it's it's not
really expected and then in some
cultures i
i could be speaking incorrectly here but
i believe in japan it's considered
insulting to leave a tip
huh like they'll refuse it like if you
leave a tip they'll like run after you
and give it back
well you know just so stressful but i've
never been to japan the most annoying
thing about dining
in america is the tax is not factored
into the freaking price
actually there's i used to think that
was so stupid so annoying but it makes
sense because each freaking
state right has a different tax rate
sales tax
so anyway let's move on now that we've
established i'm a very generous
tipper we can move on i'm so humble
i think of myself as one of the most
humble uh people on the planet
petitioned to remove kylie jenner from
the
we've got a megan okay megan
the stallion that's her name
yes with with two e's megan d stallion
yes megan d stallion
these rap kids these days man how old is
she she's 25.
let me get a look at megan d stallion
okay you do it girl
wait did you not watch the music video
no i did i just i never i watched i just
don't know who megan d
stallion is it just tripped me up when i
was reading it because like the
that's right and cardi b's whap which
stands for wet
ass p word i'm being so careful i'm
telling you i don't want to go yellow
for but it stands for what ass p word
people are very upset because kylie
jenner made an unwarranted cameo i will
say i got to say about this video i'm
going to mute it
and i'll kind of want to show you guys
this this music video
is really cool and i cannot believe the
amount of you dude it's been out for
like
just a few days two days or four days
four days
but it already has 70 million views man
that's wild
but i will say there's a couple of of
wrinkles in this music video
i'm just going to play it on like times
i do
on mute so we can kind of watch it
here's here's what i'll say about this
video i'm going to get yellowed for
playing it
but this video was number one trending
right
like i don't even think i can show you
guys this video
but it was number one trending yeah i
don't understand that i mean it's just
what is the logic
there's no logic it's outrageous and by
the way i'm not saying this video
shouldn't be on trending i'm just saying
that the standard they hold us to is
just so ridic they're so
uh
so harsh on us like damn
you know like our last podcast got
yellowed because
and i found out it's because uh we said
we made some sexual reference somewhere
in the two-hour episode
and here i can see kylie jenner's
[ __ ] in their number one trending
well you're not leaving it off the
screen so anyway it's a really creative
video with uh
the stallion and cardi b
and um then in the middle the song stops
huge dramatic moment enter
the queen bee kylie
the jaguar what do you mean queen b
i don't know queen because what's her
name
there's no b i don't know oh because oh
i don't know why i call her b
god i love her though oh that's it you
see what i mean that
we got to cut that i already cut away i
mean the next scene is cardi b
with like the pasties that are
bare like her nips are just like to the
to the nanometer cover
by pace and then her ass she's doing
splits and
i mean again it's like yeah
is that cgi her hair or what i think
it's just
fake hair i don't think it's pretty cool
yeah i know yeah it's really cool
anyway the video is amazing it's really
well done it's super cool but
um i should be number one trending but
apparently
apparently i'm not dressed like that i
guarantee you will be
so the wrinkle is that everyone was
upset that kylie was in
the video and they're like why is she
here and i have to agree that it came
out of place
it was kind of funny she kind of came
out like she was gonna
drop do something a little verse or
something
but nothing happened yeah because like
the music stops
dramatic moment who's in the hallway you
hear the stilettos
and then you're like why is kylie jenner
in this video and then she just
just goes into a room and that's it you
know
so anyway i kind of agreed that she
didn't fit but what really struck me
is not this whole controversy about
where if kylie should be in the video
and
people are making i mean it's really not
a big deal and cardi b wanted her
individual
friends they're friends so yeah she's in
the video
cardi defended it uh
but people were making a freaking
petition to remove her i mean
people are so weird imagine making a
petition like why do you care that much
just got to be more important things to
do with your life and so
you know you're the hardest wanted her
in the video
here i'm trying to find the change
here's the change.org
do you guys know that change.org doesn't
mean anything right like
like i'm so sick of petitions man it
never does anything
has a change.org petition ever achieved
anything i mean what is this site
you know they have no affiliation it's
just a website
i think it's all scammed data form i'm
almost certain they just want you to
because to sign it you have to put in
your address and info and so why do
people think
that this website change.org has any
influence they're not associated with
anything it's just a stupid website
people just want to have a little
impact like it's so easy to do
doesn't require anything from you we'll
require
signing a position on change.org is
about as impactful as doing this
i don't like her i don't like kylie
jenner in that video
not that funny okay it's it's equivalent
to
talking at a wall mm-hmm okay
people don't even see it i mean like you
see how fast they scroll
this video was perfect until we saw k
and i wanted to throw my phone
she probably feels bad but anyway i
don't really care about this and that
she didn't ruin it or anything
i punched my computer
[Laughter]
what i was amused by was the
various politicians and personalities
and all these people
who were so deeply offended
by the music video and while i will
point out that it's just
it's just so inconsistent of youtube to
trend it
i think it's hilarious the the i'm gonna
read some of these tweets
of course they're all like mega
conservatives cardi b and megan the
stallions are what happens when children
are raised without god
well that's true that part's true
without a strong
father figure well that's an assumption
well jesus is the father figured oh god
i guess their new song whap which i
heard
accidentally oh yeah he wanted to make
that i did not i didn't make that
very clear it made me want to pour holy
water in my ears and feel sorry for
future girls if this is the role model
which i heard accidentally oh my god
that's like such a trumpism isn't it
yeah oh trump said that about bill
maher's show he tweeted out once
right i watched bill maher talking about
me which i turned on accidentally i love
that
yeah he goes on secondly while i
personally take offense to the lyrics
and messaging of this song i absolutely
respect her first amendment right to
make it oh what a guy
also surprised that twitter doesn't mind
this kind of free speech but has a
problem with comfort
service free speech have we seen again i
don't know what's with
okay what i'm not getting that but
anyway he's offended
he needs to pour holy water in his ears
for just hearing about women being
sexualized
cool this person deanne lorraine
cardi b and megan the stallion just set
the entire female gender back 100 years
with their disgusting and vile whapped
song
how 100 years
100 years ago could women even vote
uh 1920 women's suffrage
happened shortly before the 1920s right
so
i think so okay so somebody said you
fact check that zach
yeah when did women get when could women
get the right to vote zach
let's find out how far back we've been
set uh was
19 1919 okay so right around that time
wow
so basically that yeah we're going to
take the vote away from women because
yeah we better take the vote away 100
years
that's awesome do not prostitute that
daughter to cause her to be a [ __ ] oh
god well that's good advice right
it's kind of self uh without a parent oh
that's
that's actually pretty funny to make
that the acronym
without a parent wap
i had no clue there was such filthy wap
song out until i was alerted on ben
shapiro's podcast
it's absolutely vile our mainstream
culture has become utter trash
girls will continue to be treated like
dirt and men will resent them
unhappiness abounds it's not like it's
funny because cardi b is
so not like she's so
i don't think she represents a weak
uh woman to anyone like she's so
the opposite of that treated like dirt
i mean she's in charge yeah you know
what i mean she's like she does whatever
she wants no she's definitely not but
she's very in charge
and she's super successful that's the
that's why the comment was
girls will continue to be treated like
dirt i mean that's an empower that right
there is an empowered woman no matter
how you want to cut it although i guess
maybe they're saying well why does
empowerment have to be
sexualized sexualized it doesn't have to
be it doesn't
hopefully well i would like to think so
but i mean it doesn't have to be but
women's sexuality has been an element
of uh suppression and control for
a long time and so yeah i mean being
able to to own and
and yeah about your sexuality it's uh
rebelling against that yeah i think it's
a timely
well it's been happening for a while but
i mean like they're pushed i guess
their artistic statement is pushing that
all the way to the [ __ ] map yeah
which is fine i mean fair enough and i
love and then ben shapiro is the king
right now he oh this this pension beer
was trending on twitter with like
a bazillion people absolutely slam dunk
all the yooping
grand slamming on him and i don't care
whatever you think about trying to
understand what you're saying they
agreed with him or did no they were
dunking on it okay
it's getting hard to follow your
language you know what a grand slam is
that's good no it's well they were grand
slamming on
okay because he also said he's the king
right now so i was like
confused the king of getting done
well he's the king of this whole
reactionary
movement on twitter i don't know
whatever you think about ben shapiro but
you gotta admit this shit's pretty funny
he goes
he reacted to this live which was super
super awesome maybe i should show the
clip before i read his tweets
but his is his wife a doctor or a
gynecologist specifically
well both of those are gynecologists
type of doctor yes dan
you said either or i said is she a
doctor or
specifically a gynecologist i i guess i
don't know i
he talks about her being a doctor all
the time so okay well
um he says as i discussed on my show my
only real concern
is that the women involved who
apparently require a bucket and mop
get the medical care they require my
doctor's wife
differential diagnosis bacterial
vaginosis
yeast infection or trichom
trichomonas trichomonas what is he
saying
he's saying that it's uh the fact that
they're wet is a
medical condition
well i don't know i miss that somehow
then
as i also discussed on the show my only
recons real concern is that the women
involved oh this is the same thing
now let me watch the clip before we kind
of talk about ben
i'm just thinking of this gift that
people always show when like the joke
flew over your head
i mean
here this is this clip was going around
how many views does it have six million
it's awesome here let's watch ben
talk about this oh i muted it earlier
lyrics you ready
[ __ ] in this house there's some [ __ ]
in this house there's some [ __ ] in
this house
there's some [ __ ] in this house hold
up
i said certified freak seven days a week
wet ass p-word
make that pull-out game weak yeah you
effin
with some wet ass p word p word is
female genitalia
bring a bucket in a mop for this wet ass
p word
give me everything you got for this wet
ass p word
beat it up n word catch a charge extra
large and extra hard
put this p word right in your face swipe
your nose like a credit card
on top i want to ride i do a kegel while
it's inside spit in my mouth look in my
eyes
this p word is wet come take a dive and
continue
uh along these lines uh and it gets
significantly significantly more vulgar
like
a lot more vulgar talk your s word bite
your lip
ask for a call while you ride that d
word censored everything you really need
right he already made his mind up for
him he's actually making me appreciate
the lyrics
i love the lyrics now that i've heard it
it's so funny like swipe your nose to my
ass like a credit card
yeah how do you not even acknowledge
that that's funny bring a bucket on a
mop
that's funny yeah it's funny the fact
for him to be like well that's a medical
condition
people were people were crying on them
they were saying like well the fact that
ben
is acknowledging that he's never met and
encountered a wet vagina is the funniest
self-owned ever
yeah that's i yeah that's what i was
laughing at like hey
now get your boots in your coat for this
wet ass p word
pay my tuition just imagine people who
are his like
fans of ben shapiro watching this and
being like
and not laughing how is what you're
doing now yeah how
is what you're doing meant to uh uh uh
offend me i mean imagine
if you're like oh it's just bro
swipe your nose in my ass like a credit
card
keyword pay my tuition just to kiss me
on this wet ass b
right so this is d guys this this is
what feminists fought for
this is what the feminist movement was i
actually agree i think the fact that
women
he's being ironic he's saying right this
is what feminism has come to but he's
right the fact that women can express
themselves in this way i do think is
definitely a sign of of a lot of ground
covered i mean it's not
especially in hip-hop it's always like
the guys you know
yeah it's always like you'd see the guy
in charge
but the girls around him i went to the
party but she's starting it she's like
yeah why she's the exactly ela
you think about you go back to like the
golden days of rapport or like easy
e cruising down the street and my
six-four like all this is about
it's just the male version of this and
so and so it is
ironically because he doesn't have
benjamin has famously made like the most
obtuse comments about rap
ever actually can you pull up what he
said he's clearly talking about a
culture
and a music and a genre that he has no
understanding of so
you should hear what he said about
hip-hop as a genre
it's not uh it's not really about you
know women being treated
as independent full rounded human beings
it's about what aspie word and if you
say anything differently it's because
you're a misogynist you see
i don't think you're misogynistic you're
a [ __ ] idiot that's just what the
song is about
yeah i just think you're missing the
point
it's so funny what ask b word and if you
say anything differently it's because
you're a misogynist you see i just love
that they have to frame it so that if
they're wrong
it's because they're uh being
marginalized
it's just stupid look this is what cardi
b
is all about that's her thing and she's
taking it all the way
right i'm like i'm personally not like
that and i don't
sexualize myself on my instagram or
anything like that and no one has a
problem with that you can go either way
you want
i mean i agree that like on a certain
degree
um there's a conversation to have on how
when when women sexualize themselves
their like instagram will do better
mm-hmm
tick tock all of a sudden they're
starting to dance with bikinis
instead of wearing clothes shame it's a
conversation
that is worth discussing but that's
different
i mean i you see the same thing with
dude dudes who are jacked and look good
and then they're always shirtless they
get more followers too
yeah it just so happens that we
sexualize things different like a dude
who's jacked
with six-pack is a sexual being where
you know you a female the less clothes
they it's the same thing
it's the same exact thing i mean like
where's this conversation
when like i'm i'm sure there's male
versions where they're like
wearing very little clothes and their
shirts are off and all this [ __ ]
i mean why doesn't that strike the same
chord
when dudes are all sexualized in their
music videos
because of misogyny so oh so maybe he's
right maybe he is a misogynist
well well i don't know enough about him
to make that claim to be frank but he's
definitely missing the point
really uh really really really really
vulgar
okay uh you got that tweet for me about
hip hop
oh here it is this is [ __ ] awesome
you guys are gonna love this
this is the best [ __ ] ever you're gonna
love this my case against rap
is i have the musical case against trap
and then i'll get to the cultural case
so the musical case against rap is that
in in my view
and the view of my music theorist father
who who went to
music school the there are three
elements to music there's
harmony there's there is melody and
there's rhythm and rap only fulfills one
of these
the rhythm section that there's not a
lot of melody and there's not a lot of
harmony
you were so ignorant the fact they could
even go on air and say that is
crazy he thinks this is all rap is
like like there's you've not listened to
enough rap
effectively spoken rhythm and so it's
not actually a form
of music it's a form of rhythmic
so speaking the subjectivity of me just
not enjoying rap all that much
uh it's what i've said before is not me
i remember being longer but you get the
idea yeah boy
wait i think i remember him having a
really great tweet about it if you can
pull that up
uh to be honest i i think he's he's
tweeted about this countless times uh
i want to see him okay well he and her
zach
please yeah let's get it you're so kind
anyway i know a lot of people like ben
shapiro and again
i think on this one i don't know enough
about him so i'm not trying to go to war
with people about ben shapiro
you know what i mean i'm not i'm not
attacking your uh
identity as a ben shapiro fan i think on
this
one issue of rap he d he's very
ignorant he says
fact rap isn't music
and if you think it is you're stupid
what a [ __ ] weirdo what a weirdo
we're now
where's 2012 well it's still done a long
time
i mean yeah obviously a bad take but
fact rap isn't music and if you think it
is you're stupid
that's the thoughts of a great intellect
oh yeah yeah
you're stupid anyway again
so oh here so this was the my favorite
thing that came out of it which the
moment i saw him reading those lyrics
remind me of you guys remember vince
staples uh
the lady what was this song i really
liked that vince staples song
some soccer mom was crying super
offended by his lyrics
and then sometimes called the north
north yeah
and so she started crying and then
she read the lyrics to the whole song
maybe i should just show it because it's
such a classic i think we've talked
about it on the show i think so too but
just
just to uh just to refresh for people
who don't know because it's just
it's literally so funny and skyler's in
the background so
if she comes up here and wants me to
hold her she might
okay so this is literally what ben
shapiro did
she was reading the lyrics about how so
i'm on my way taking the kids to school
and this morning i have an 11 year old
daughter aaliyah
she loves that 104.5
radio station it's like the top hits
right
i remember listening to the top hits
when i was a kid like britney spears and
christina aguilera
and backstreet boys and then sync and
nowadays
also all very sexualized yeah it's not
the same right not the same at all
um oh they cut out her crying she
started crying and
this rap song comes on guys i could not
believe
what i was hearing and as a mom
it infuriated me like why is this
on here and it like i started to get
tears in my eyes it upset me so much
and my 11 year old daughter listens to
this radio station
i i looked up the song and i looked at
the lyrics
i cannot believe this stuff is on the
radio
i'm sorry
okay i'm gonna read it to you and i want
you
to just listen to the words some of this
i'm gonna cuss
i'm just gonna repeat what it says
trigger warning all right
okay i'm trying not to get claimed here
but i want to play a little bit
how do i do this without getting claimed
i can't yeah
she goes oh we could do it for the
members only and cut it members only
if you want to hear us watch this whole
thing
subscribe and be a member and you can
watch it there
right dan yeah um isn't she just gonna
read it though why do you think no but
there's music she's playing
they remix it with the beat yeah so
members only
go watch this epic reaction so
let me play you vince's response because
it was so perfect
vince said it's pathetic to attack
someone for having an opinion on feeling
some type of way
for wanting her children not to be
exposed to something because i'm 100
sure my mother would have loved for her
children not to be exposed to gang life
the difference is it wasn't on the radio
it was in our house it was outside
it was in our schools it was at our
churches it was everywhere that we were
so it was kind of a little bit harder if
i have children one day i would hope
that they are never exposed to that
but when you have people who are able to
you know just write people off as they
don't have an opinion or feeling or
motive behind the things they say
that's the corny part you're worse than
her because she shared her opinion
she never once said anything negative
about me at all her statement was that
she doesn't understand how
this is getting to major airwaves which
is debatable it's fair
for her to feel that way and most of all
she kind of felt bad about the fact that
it was possible that things
these things could actually really
happen
shouldn't we be you know happy that
someone actually is considering the fact
that the stuff that i'm singing about
that really happens
is being passed off as fable or just
ignoring it
it's kind of an interesting take he's
like yeah this [ __ ] happens it is that
it is that sad but i thought it was
actually
because people were really like clowning
on her and he was
he was like hardcore defending her and
every time people asked him about it i
thought that was sweet
regardless we were here to talk about
ben shapiro when i was setting that up
because of course
the moment i saw him reading the lyrics
like that i was like oh boy
again so of course dr grandi grande
delivered and what in my opinion was the
best one and i saw a lot of them
this is this was this was by far the
best one
so good shout out to dr
grande
there's some horrors in this house
i said certified freakouts seven days a
week
there's some wet ass keywords pull out
game week
yeah yeah yeah
yeah you happen with some wet ass
keywords bring
give me everything you've got for this
wet ass fur
speed it up inward catch a charge extra
large and extra hard
right in your face swipe your nose like
a credit card hop on top
if i want to ride i do a kegel well it's
inside spit in my mouth
look in my eyes this keyword is wet come
take it dive
and continue uh along these lines
uh and it gets significantly
significantly more vulgar
like oh a lot more uh here's a part
where
ben goes on to say that um
there's something that is going on here
that is not biologically normal
and by the way the song is so unsexy
that it frankly says china getting wet
is not biologically normal
what does it mean it's just the funniest
cell phone ever
it's like somebody describing what
amounts to
a serious condition that requires the
care of a doctor
so fortunately i know a doctor who's my
wife
and so i asked her who doesn't know
anything about wet vagina either i mean
the layers of self-own is so good and
she looked at the lyrics herself
and after being kind of appalled by them
obviously
she had a few sort of indicators here on
how she could diagnose the the vaginal
condition that apparently these women
are suffering from
so there are a few sort of giveaways
there are a few sort of giveaways
what is this we gotta do this dan
watch the rest of our podcast become a
member oh i like this
i'm just gonna i'm gonna block all the
video
after like an hour first of all a bucket
and a mop
for this so he plays the whole thing but
just covers it
that's crazy look at this they actually
do that and that is
from from 30 minutes he covers the whole
thing with a
time stamp or watermark isn't that
annoying yes
that's awesome so first of all she had
to clarify whether wet ass p word was a
description
like how badly do you need to see him
talking though at the same time
the pure or whether one of the clinical
symptoms here was also diarrhea
diarrhea bring a bucket and a mop so
this suggests
that there's an awful lot of um not to
be too graphic but some sort of uh
medical discharge that's happening here
like a lot i think it suggests that
there's uh
humor something you're not aware of it's
like it's a condition you're not
familiar with
i think it's a hyperbolic there ben i
think he may be over
analyzing the statement he's like well
okay so she's got a lot of moisture down
there and uh it doesn't seem medically
correct so i consulted with the doctor
they said well is it maybe it's diarrhea
maybe it's a maybe it could be some kind
of medical condition
then you really gotta go to urgent care
yeah that's what he's saying
so i went to a specialist i consulted a
world-renowned doctor uh
uh jennifer dodetta we had a hour-long
conversation i read a medical journal
it's like it's just a joke bro watch me
write a lot too much because that's a
symptom of something that is not
going great oh yeah there's science
problems pretty good
yeah um and i say that because hop on
top i want to ride i do a kegel while
it's inside so there's some signs of
some actual
clinical prolapse which is which is a
problem
[Music]
wait is he trying to be funny i don't
think so
i don't think so a clinical prolapse
because she wanted to do a kegel and
that sounds great i mean that sounds
like something i would recommend
also there's some there's some talk
about um where this person is putting
their nose
and uh and and there's some talk about
smelling
right there's a there's a line here
about gagging and choking
which suggests that perhaps perhaps
there's an odor issue here
come on it's kidding
from putting from sniffing the butt oh
dude
this is hilarious but he's not laughing
this has to be a joke at some point in
here there's a reference to diabetes
about uh about a person who uh engages
in particular activity and ends up
diabetic
which is just a serious ph imbalance so
i asked my wife oh my god
this is great i really think he's
kidding how could you say
that there's an odor issue from sniffing
an [ __ ] gagging i mean imagine this
i have to imagine that you sniff the
[ __ ] at a new gag
that's [ __ ] incredible for a
differential diagnosis for the sake of
these ladies in case they need to
go to the doctor i mean like this this
is a problem i mean like
if if this is real like there's water
pouring out the front doors of this
place and that ain't water guys i mean
that's that's why i'm being told that
ain't water
so the medical diagnosis it's new it's
news to be he doesn't know what it is
yeah
how ben is not a is not a sexy man so
[Laughter]
i think i don't i don't i don't have a
hard time believing that ben's never
encountered a wet vagina
i mean when you hear him talk it's not
very sexual
it almost makes me think like
when it's when he like performs at
sex acts it's like chalk probably like
chalk inside
he just goes and like
chalk comes out oh
no that that was fine here was her
differential her differential diagnosis
my wife the doctor
was either these women are suffering
from bacterial vaginosis
or a yeast infection or my wife
suggested
most probably they are suffering from
trichomonas
so just did you i don't think his wife's
ever experienced being turned on before
because they're both like super orthodox
you know
medical advice yeah put aside the
empowerment put i mean i understand how
empowering it is for women to sing
about the the moisture state of their
genitals
and i i understand that anybody who
criticizes this as reductive
of female sexuality and or of putting
out images of females
as over-sexualized in a way that is
negative that puts a negative image
we're just watching this
right now
still visualize them in my head you know
i know exactly i was like
i love that they have to blur them out
you don't want to even see
what we need to do ela is do this on our
show of watching him
you're behind two paywalls effectively
we didn't even pay for you guys to watch
him at least
yeah for members only we'll pay
oh geez i guess that's it eh we did it
all
i wanted to talk about some other stuff
but we gotta throw it into our special
segment yeah oh well we've got a really
exciting segment
um dax flame as you guys know he was on
the podcast recently with
with idubbbz who made a documentary
about him called ice cream man
he is a youtuber an author a comedian
he's a renaissance fan he's a man of
many talents and skills and interests
and so we're going to throw it to dax
part one is underway and i just think
that um
i think it's really exciting to be able
to have this be a part of our show so
with that being said let us let us delve
into part one
back with us today on the show is the
smoothie enthusiast
the ice cream man himself
dax flame we have what we've got a
special project we've been working on
here
um something that i think is going to be
captivating and intriguing to to
everybody and maybe even to bring
like some big changes to the earth it's
not just
entertainment we're here to actually
impact
the world as we see it dax how are you
doing have you had any
interesting smoothies lately i just had
one before
we started because it's morning time at
the moment and yeah
every day tell me what was inside the
smoothie
uh mangoes peaches oat milk
protein powder a few other things um
but yeah also there's ripple effects of
what's a seemingly small
thing going back to the series
can have a even though you said it big
effect on the world
maybe even through a small thing ripple
effects but yeah this smoothie was good
and
so i don't know well i think that we're
not
it's not a ripple effect i think it's a
meteorite smashing into the earth
but we're about to unveil here okay
yeah hopefully yeah i think so
but getting back to the smoothies do you
drink anything
do you live on smoothies no i it's my
breakfast every day though
and do you ever throw a wild card
ingredient in there just to kind of see
what happens
no no no it's usually the same exact
thing
it's the same exact smoothie so dax
um tell us about what we've what we're
gonna get ourselves in here today
you have a video you prepared part one
for us
it's kind of like a film noir i would
even describe it as
yeah so it's um it's a series
that is going to evolve as it is
made um i will be taking in any
information that comes my way
i want to be a neutral journalist at
while while making it
and i think it could potentially just
come off as a tribute piece in a way
that sort of just teaches valuable
lessons as i learned them and i will
share it
but also i'm open to anything i learned
and so
we will really see how it goes and i'm
hoping that there is some genuine change
on my end
and even a discovery of change on the
punches
we're of course talking about um charlie
poof puth who is one i would describe
maybe as your arch
nemesis or my teenage
archnemesis yeah currently i don't want
to label him as anything
uh uh i do have
if i'm being the most honest mixed
feelings but
i want to just be open to anything so i
like to become friends with him actually
but also i'm just we'll see so you think
like you'd obviously have a bias against
charlie puth for all for the meanness
he's
he's thrust on you but you want to try
to overcome that as a
impartial journalist yes
and also i wouldn't even i think on an
unconscious level because on the surface
level i'll just say no
i'm fine that's years ago but i think
that it's important to be honest with
yourself
and so we'll see we'll see yeah i
definitely think of him as a villain of
some sort
and if i can even ask what's the deal
with his eyebrow because it almost looks
like a style but then when you go back
in time he
it looks like a like he has a scar or
something from a diaper it's this
yes he has a scar from a dog attack from
when he was two i've been learning
a lot about him so i think it was almost
life-threatening
wow wow so that kind of yeah that is an
interesting
do you know if he has a dog phobia to
this day or is he is he all good with
dogs
i haven't seen any videos of him with
dogs so i don't know interesting
yeah well here's what i proposed let's
watch part one
and then we can discuss uh from there so
without further ado we have the truth
about pouth part one the beginning
of an epic journey of discovery charlie
puth is one of the most successful
up-and-coming pop stars performing duets
with everyone from meghan trainor to
pitbull
and recording four multi-platinum hits
i'm dax flame
actor author and most importantly one of
the original youtube stars
back in 2007 when charlie was still a
complete unknown
and i was at the height of my youtube
fame charlie used to send me very
discouraging hate messages about my
singing voice i received
thousands of comments and messages like
these but charlie's might have been most
vicious
and to this day i'm still too shy to
sing in front of anyone
but i'm not perfect the same year that
charlie sent me those messages
i actually made a video jealously hating
on many youtubers who had more
subscribers than me
i know that i've completely changed as a
person since recording that toxic video
and so i'm assuming that charlie has two
since sending his messages
i don't know that he's changed as a
matter of fact
i don't know much about him at all and
i'd like to find out
before i share my goal for this series
with you i'd like to share what my goal
is
not my goal is not revenge my goal is
not to accuse him of anything
or to drag him down my goal is not to
slander his name
my goal is understanding
like 15 different synths in the record
was pretty exciting
when i listen to charlie's music and
watch interviews with him
i get the impression that he's a very
talented and funny pop star
someone who i could actually see myself
being friends with and hanging out with
[Music]
if this impression is accurate if he's
the same in person as he appears in
interviews
then i'd like to understand the journey
he underwent to becoming who he is now
from who he used to be i will be open to
any and all information that comes my
way
positive or negative but my hope is that
over the course of this series i'm able
to conduct interviews with those closest
to charlie
confirming my impression that he's
actually a very great person
and that i'm able to learn about what
steps he took to change
and that i'm able to confront my
insecurities over singing
and maybe even explore music as a
potential outlet
while also additionally maybe even
meeting up with charlie and exchanging
apologies over the past
and potentially becoming friends and
also delivering some helpful life
lessons to viewers along the way
lastly this is not just a series for
charlie puth fans
this is a series for anyone interested
in the themes of personal growth
forgiveness overcoming insecurities
dealing with the internet hatred
following your dreams forming
friendships having courage
and ultimately whether or not people
really
change let me look at this comment
first of all on motivate i'm moved
you're not
oh so cool and that was sent to you
directly or it was a comment on a video
uh i would receive messages from him oh
i think i know i think it was a brief
uh exchange of messages i received
thousands of comments and messages that
were hate as everyone does
um but i think since his resonated more
because
normally with those you push them to the
back of your mind but whenever you
uh see this public figure come
and that you can't avoid them then it
brings those things that you push back
up to the surface so yeah
so at the time at the time we sent you
this comment which i'll read in a moment
was was he at all famous well
you don't have to read that oh i'm going
to read it but but but
but when he sent you this message was he
at all famous or was he a nobody
no he was not famous uh and that is the
interesting thing to me
is um is uh
yeah the the the reasons behind it
and um i've actually
in a future episode i'm hoping to
interview someone who is who was close
with him back then
that i recently
that's exciting but yeah you know we
could discover
great things about him maybe it was a
misunderstanding totally maybe we'll
discover more dark stuff
but the scary thing is like there are so
many people
whenever someone is that famous and is
generating that much income and stuff
there's so many people who rely on him
too who will want to stop me if there is
anything to hide
so hopefully there is nothing to hide
and like like that's that's like my just
being paranoid but
but no that's a really good point you
know it's like
but also maybe he has nothing to hide
and we'll just discover great things
but either way he should know we're
digging
yeah yeah for sure um and digging for
goodness
like or batteries whatever's there we're
digging
you know sometimes sometimes when you
dig you don't you just don't know what
you're gonna unearth and i think that's
what he has to be aware of
yes well and then again i do think
because he wasn't famous i do think it's
worth mentioning that this may not even
have been him
uh yeah there could be another charlie
puth
do you do you remember the avatar do you
remember the face
like how sure are you that this is the
same booth that sent the message oh
well uh because he's i remember it was a
youtube musician
yeah who wanted to be famous who had the
name
because that's such a memorable name so
if anyone think questions the validity i
think it's like
like you'll just have to trust me and
once i meet him he'll confirm
and yeah we'll see okay that's
convincing
so basically i remember like a purple
sort of avatar or something
um but more than that i just remember
his name and i remember
a hateful connotation to it um
to the interaction uh quite like
messages quite negative
um the thing about sending a direct
message too is like it's more hateful
it's more
it's hidden also it's what hidden
right it's in a way more
than a public comment because yeah the
public comment you almost don't even
assume that the person will actually
read it in a way
yeah you know like and it's it's all it
also implies the question
he publicly seems to have changed when i
watch interviews like i get a genuine
instinct
this is a nice person and i would like
to know him uh but also there's lots of
nice people so i can make lots of
me lots of nice but yeah if he was doing
that in public back then
is he still doing something or in
private back then is he still doing
something in private now
probably not it's just interesting these
will be like what makes it interesting
let me read this and also i would like
to talk to a therapist for
like if any of your audience is a
therapist uh for a future episode if
they are interesting
interested to meet me in public i could
interview them about some
potential things uh and i could pay them
like for their time or whatever
no we i think we're we're working on
finding someone for that already okay
let me read on let me read the comment
your voice makes me sick
your latest singing video was the most
embarrassing thing i've seen
though and this is just the gist of what
his messages were oh so he sent you
multiple messages i think there were
maybe
if i'm remembering correctly it was one
brief exchange
of maybe two or three messages and so
when he sent you a message like this how
did you respond
i probably responded angrily back yeah
man i killed her to read that can you
just like what would
what what's a comment that you at that
age would have said to him can you
kind of like go back to that um if
if could you read me the first sentence
of what i will see yeah what is written
here
your voice makes me sick your latest
singing video was the most embarrassing
thing i've ever
seen so i probably would have said like
i have i have a great singing voice if
my voice is not good
why do i get all these views um and
probably would have like
and maybe i would have attacked him too
i don't remember probably not actually
but um but
yeah i think deep down i kind of knew i
wasn't the best singer but i really
genuinely enjoyed it
let me continue the only reason you're
on the most subscribed list is because
people laugh at you
your voice is almost as ugly as your
face
you would lose in any fight and you
should be embarrassed to have a voice so
sad it was like nails on a chalkboard
and you'll never be a professional this
is a recreation
you should be this is the name of
yourself and then it says
recreation message because the messages
have been lost to time
but but the pain is what matters
like you're recreating the pain is real
and you're reinterpreting that
so this is a recreation based on your
memory of the
yeah i'm really reluctant to even say
that it's a recreation i just wanted to
say that for
uh legal purposes because i think that
the reason the message i know that
immediately people
question the validity once they realize
that the reason that it is
a recreation though is because youtube
deleted all of
the messages direct messaging is no
longer
a option whereas like on instagram right
you can dm someone yeah uh
youtube used to have that now they don't
so
i received messages from him and they
were like that
they could have been worse uh i i
originally
wrote a draft of that feel free to edit
any of this out too
i originally wrote a draft of that that
was even harsher
based off my memory but i didn't want to
like
to have it like i didn't want to use the
f word in it or i don't remember if he
actually did or whatever well i think
you conveyed it well
certainly and i mean yeah that that
those are some
bitter hurtful words that's a that's a
young man who's clearly just very
jealous of your success i would say
and someone who is who
who thinks they deserve your success
and they don't understand uh they don't
understand
and were you dealing with
a crazy amount of hate at that time
oh yeah for sure for sure but the reason
that
someone like like those messages would
stick out a bit more
is maybe just because he became famous
later and also they were very
uh targeting my singing voice which
wasn't
as targeted by hate back then so i
realized that
puth i'm just putting this together was
on the feature of
wiz khalifa see you again which is like
the you said is the third most popular
video on youtube youtube video of all
time and maybe the most popular in
spotify of all time
5 billion almost so the booth has been
out here
he's been he's been out here so
obviously we can't play it but this is
the song that was
the paul walker yeah rest in peace paul
walker song
why is that funny dan how dare you what
would you laugh about recipes paul
walker do you know how
that affected people five billion views
i'm just thinking back to our guests the
other week who uh
who wanted to erect the paul walker
statue oh okay
so this is furious i don't know why you
find that funny either
um furious seven wow how many furiouses
are we up to man that was furious seven
that happened so long ago and they're
still making those movies
so i feel like now i do i get a lot more
context
to um yeah you can't escape that
yeah exactly that you can't escape it
i'm so familiar with this
grocery stores restaurants right
anywhere you go graduation ceremonies
i'm sure
would you like possibly for charlie poof
to sing see you again at your funeral
well i uh don't want to think about my
death
oh okay fair enough yeah
good good right but he would it would
theoretically if i died
i i yeah sure it would be great
if we became friends actually and i
happened to pass away
uh while he still had a like great voice
and stuff um then yeah that'd be great
if you sing it at my funeral
do you think that and that would be a
great healing moment too
it would just prove even though you
don't pump things
i said even though you'd be dead it
would still be a great healing moment
it would prove that we had healed
already or maybe it would be
just healing for him if it wasn't and
that would be sad if we never made up
and then
he just showed up that would be weird
do you think that you would share is it
okay for you to share that song with
paul walker or maybe he should write a
new one for you at your funeral
like it would be called uh like because
it's called see you again
maybe yours could be called uh i'm sorry
and goodbye yeah it could just cover
justin bieber
sorry song just i'm sorry and goodbye
yeah we'll think about that maybe you
know be cool if you wrote a song for
your funeral
like and actually i would appreciate
that because
that would prove that before passing we
had come to some sort of
yeah meeting point and healed
yes um it would be darker if i had
passed away
and he just like showed up and sang it
for his own healing purposes while
everyone there knows that i had beef
with him
like like so that would be like the
bad version of it but yeah the other one
like theoretically
that'd be wild if just showed up
unannounced to your funeral
seeing pouth become famous
resurfaced with him a lot of these
negative
feelings you associate with being hated
on the internet so long ago
yeah like going into a restaurant and
hearing
see you again come on or uh hearing it
come
come on over the speakers uh all of a
sudden i'm taken back
to like theoretically what could have
been
like a different career bathroom well i
don't even want to go there and say that
i could have had a
music career but it is a thought in my
mind
so but there's almost like a it's almost
like a ptsd trigger where
i almost wonder if you even have like a
lot you could probably even sue him for
inflicting emotional pain on you because
like the more successful he becomes
the more damaging he is you every time
you hear him on the radio
well i don't think i'm going to try to
sue him because i'm well theoretically
changed and i would like him to have a
good life and and hopefully become
friends with him
but that is an interesting thought yeah
we could end the series with either a
reunion or a lawsuit
[Laughter]
if you'll pay for the lawsuit i don't
know if i wanna yeah
i don't know if i wanna be better
man well let's see maybe we could do a
gofundme and see how badly people want
you to sue
charlie all right i'm thinking we would
you think that you guys could be friends
what do you think
like i think dax can be friends with
anybody if i can answer for you i don't
know that this booth guy
i don't know if he's ready to be friends
no that'll be interesting to find out
but i don't know anything that's like
uh sorry i cut you off oh no go ahead
do you have anything that would be a
a deal breaker if he's like oh he's he
wants to play video games all the time
and you're like
i'm out or you mean if you want to be
like real friends
he's uh he's all about smoking weed and
you're
not yeah uh well i don't see us hanging
out every day or anything like i'm sure
he's super busy and also there's corona
so i
i would be a backyard hang if anything
but it could start from there like start
from like a
like a play interview for this web
series and clear up the past and
apologize
and um that is important to note that
there was never an apology
uh not the biggest deal but we'll see we
need an apology
because those are hurtful words and i
mean i think we
i think our goals need to be apology
a backyard at the very least an apology
okay or and then at the very best a duet
at the very worst a lawsuit
and and i and i'm hoping that there's
tabloids and papers we should send this
out
this clip too to tabloids and [ __ ]
because
they kind of maybe we should wait until
there's a better conclusion right or
whatever no no i want the story i just
want people to kind of get it on the
radar that you know maybe there's more
than meets the eye to this poof
character
that's that's cool and honestly i do see
it having very positive
i want to be open to anything but i do
see it having a very positive
feel and uh i do think like like it's
the last 20 seconds of the video you
played is supposed to evoke the
uh exciting inspiring effects that the
series could have
right
hmm is there any chance you guys getting
the octagon together
if it goes south the octagon
no he beat the hell out of me no he's
really
muscular like i don't know if you saw
that he seems kind of short though
we could play basketball versus each
other that's an outdoor activity
basketball
yeah he is pretty fit he's fit but he's
kind of short i don't know if you've got
like that rage in you like some people
have the rage and they can just
overcome physical opposition no no in
fighting
do you think you have that rage that
like inner flame that just kind of
would allow you to have superhuman
strength during the fight
or no i don't know
yeah i don't know maybe uh but i don't
want to fight him
oh it's important to clear up and and um
yeah i think if you did send it to
tabloids and whatnot i would just be a
little worried
that that his team might come from me
and destroy
my youtube channel like have talked to
youtube because he's a bigger
no no don't worry we have we have
connections they can't touch you
you're you're made man okay and
it's only gonna be good too it will
reflect positively on everyone involved
unless there are skeletons in the closet
but i don't think there are
well you might be that skeleton in his
closet dax
mine isn't that bad and honestly i try
to present
it doesn't affect me at all there is a
little seed inside me that's like
well maybe there is there is some doubt
maybe it did affect me a little bit
as with any hate comment
but maybe more so and
so i'll just be honest open explore it
well i'm excited i'm thrilled i'm
excited
i cannot wait to see where this goes
we're going to have another we're going
to try to do an installment every week
as this story develops
wow yeah i love how you put the clip
together
those uh shots of you wandering and
thank you and did you see on the like
title card
how he he goes from out of focus oh yeah
i didn't notice that oh yeah very nice
detail
notice that big time i also noticed the
uh
the building that you were hanging out
in front of says uh
what did it say charles's music or
something yeah the day that y'all
asked me to do this series
i went for a hike and on the way back
almost as if a sign from god
i saw this building and i pulled over
and started the film so every episode
uh that's the after the title card i
plan to introduce the episode name in
front of that building
episode two is called assumptions
all right well we will see you next week
dax
we wish you well in your investigations
i do want to say i'm happily reading
your
new book cool exciting
dax flames guide to making money as an
influencer
yeah which is great i mean we all need
help in that
realm so fantastic
all right dax great chatting with you we
will catch up with you again next week
as we become uh as we come closer and
closer to the truth
about the booth can we just call him the
booth that's kind of a good name
if you'd like to yeah the booth would
you like me to change the title of the
series or
no
all right dax take care
well we've done it all we've said it all
people said we wouldn't come back but
here we are and next
episode uh we'll be back again
against all odds against all forces that
conspiracy will try
no we will we will prevail
we will prevail so we'll see you then
guys thank you for joining us as always
thank you to our members
see you guys on discord and um
god bless we'll see you guys there thank
you god bless
jobless yeah ja bless oh
job i thought you were making fun of
unemployed people not jobless
jobless okay
[Music]